voici leur nid
la colonie de chauves-souris a élu
domicile dans les fondations de cette
cité HLM environ 100 spécimens selon les
locataire le jour où on devine leur
passage à l'odeur aux traces de
déjections laissées sur les murs et les
fenêtres
[Musique]
ça la tombée de la nuit comme il y a les
chansons qui passent
près de la pente donc je crois que mes
enfants avec le sac à bas on est obligé
de faire vite pour rentrer pour
justement que les chansons ne puissent
pas arriver sur nous ils ont déjà fait
caca aussi sur la tête de mon conjoint
donc c'est très difficile pour nous de
vivre dans ces circonstances dans ces
conditions pas question pour Julia de
s'acquitter des 7 euros demandez chaque
mois pour entretenir les espaces communs
que la locataire juge un saluebre
social a pourtant tenté de chasser les
nuisibles en ajoutant plus d'éclairage
dans les espaces communs ou en
installant cette grille de protection
bien que mal ajustée à la hauteur du sol
nous avons fait ensuite pulvériser un
répulsif donc là aussi ça a réduit mais
malheureusement on arrive toujours pas à
résoudre ce problème parce que on a
d'autres ouvertures et notamment les
portes de Hall des immeubles qui restent
ouvertes jour et nuit donc je fais appel
aussi aux résidents pour qu'ils le fasse
preuve de responsabilité pour que cette
pour que ces portes restent fermées
puisque les chauves-souris passent
maintenant par les portes de Hall et on
pointe même les escaliers d'autres
tentatives seront menées mais si la
situation continue de s'enliser le
responsable d'agence se dit prêt à
envisager de reloger les 29 familles de
cet immeuble